bon j'espère que ça marche juste checker
que tout marche avant 2 avant de me
lancer
ce que j'ai on a eu un par un souci
technique mais une petite commande à
changer l'adresse du du switch de
duchess comme il ya eu un petit un petit
truc avec la connexion et je veux juste
vérifier que que ce soit bon et après on
va se lancer
on a eu les arénas alors attendez ça
marche voilà ouais ça marche
donc c'est bon nickel je vais mourir le
chat histoire de vous avoir joué ouvrir
le chat duchess comme tv histoire d'être
bon et on va pouvoir se lancer
tranquillement jeu lancé par un petit
blitz et on va attendre que favari
francky d'un petit un petit souci pour
démarrer l'ordi et moi je veux faire un
petit blitz tranquillement je vais me
faire un petit bide tranquillement
histoire de lancer le truc allez hop en
matière il ya déjà des vues heures qui
me propose
on va prendre à leur apprendre super
juge je crois que c'est le premier à
avoir défié on voit bien l'échiquier
c'est bien cadrer tout est bien cadré on
va jouer contre super du jus alors je
propose qu'on fasse cavalier à 3 contre
super du jus on va voir un peu ce qui
nous fait le super du jus 45 1 c'est pas
c'est pas n'importe quel super vu juste
et le super vu 45 alors il nous fait des
quatre des cinq on va faire des quatre
donc et on va transposer voyons on
transpose dans un des quatre des cinq
dans un gambit dame alors il nous prend
avec ses sacs on va loin en vie d'un
amas et couleurs inversées
alors on va on va laisser jouer comme
s'il avait les blancs et on va jouer
avec un temps avec les noirs mais avec
un temps de plus on va voir ce qu'on va
voir ce qu'il fait donc ça donne
vraiment une slave
pour les blancs donc pour moi avec un
temps de plus donc j'ai fait le petit le
petit château de la slave et on va jouer
comme une mayrand avec beckham ou b2
super jo occupants se débrouille pas mal
hein ce qui fait c'est plutôt correct
j'ai essayé de piéger voyez je joue
contre un joueur qui a un classement
moindre donc j'essaye de jouer un intrus
cas couleurs inversées en disant on
tient peut-être qui connaît peut-être il
se rend pas compte mais pour le moment
il gère assez bien donc c'est vraiment
pouvoir ont la même position avec les
noirs avec le foin en fuite en fait il
ya cette position qui était au ritz avec
le fou en d3 bon iran convard ok donc ça
c'est pas mal et on va essayer de jouer
avec 4 ok hommage aux quatre dans les
moeurs en mai le fou en e2 plus tôt et
dans les antilles mais rend detroit ont
pas marre je pense exactement la même
position avec la dame ans et sept dans
la théorie sais pas si ça n'arrange pas
lui au final d'avoir cette dame ici
parce que maintenant sur pions prend
cavaliers prend cavaliers prend fou
prend f5 fou des cinq échecs roi suite
je suis peut-être pas si bien mais bon
j'étais pas se passe pas une super
partie pédagogique pour le moment
ok il fait h6 pas mettre la tour en 1
on a livré une série qui l'unît à salut
alors être là d'avancé 2 raconter
n'importe quoi tout à l'heure quand il
faisait f5 y avait foule france et si
c'est qu'elle prend 1,5 à noter un bain
je suis pas encore puis pas encore très
réveillés rappelant qu est la dame
bonjour n'a pas du tout pris le dessus
pour la peine ils traversèrent qui joue
plutôt bien pour le moment juste le
petit kwasi ce qui à mon avis n'était
pas obligatoire mais on ne réussit pas à
jouer le coup libérateur c4 pour libérer
le fou et donc on réussit pas vraiment
apprendre à prendre l'aventage bon
écouter parfois on est pas mal
on est pas mal on va peut-être faire à
trois ça me permettra peut-être un jour
de préparer ces quatre pour le moment je
garde le statu quo au centre et le pion
à trois ça sert à protéger le pion
bécade pour préparer du c4 encore
qu'aujourd'hui sur ces captures et
peut-être des cartes on pourrait essayer
de faire c'est 5
alors maintenant on va faire payer prend
2,4 et sur cavaliers prend l'idée c'est
de faire fou prend donc on a gardé toute
cette tension centrale y aura un
problème sur la colonne des avec la dame
qui est pas très bien placé espions aux
cinq qui va rester en prison clore un
cabine menace claire c'est fou prend ses
six cavaliers prend 1,5
il part la menace mais il part pas là le
deuxième menace qui est qui et prend 1,5
direct pour jouer sur le clouage donc il
a fini par craquer la tension 1
on a gardé la tension assez longtemps au
centre et c'est c'est super du jus qui
finalement a libéré cette tension en
premier un poil trop tôt donc ici ils
menacent maintenant le cavalier donc on
va revenir en f3 comme ça on protège le
pion h deux ans la position n'est pas
encore gagnant d'un parce que s'il
réussit à bien bloquer les le trio de
pions l'a donc surtout le pion c1 qui
est bloqué la part par la dame a
fortiori qui réussit à visser sur la
case c4 ont réussi pas faire rejouer le
pion plus bon ils menacent de prendre le
cavalier et de prendre h donc on va
faire h3 ça nous permet de chasser le
fou et en plus de protéger le pion et
maintenant notre idée c'est clairement
c4 à la nôtre menacé ces quatre puisque
si on fait ces quatre qu'on va
d'ailleurs jouer il peut pas prendre à
cause de tout reprendre et 6 mais c'est
du gros caca parce qu'il ya tout
reprendre un d'abord tourcoing main et
dames france et 4 heureusement chez fou
prend bessette qui sauvent mais c était
une erreur tactique de ma part qui n'est
sans grande conséquence parce qu'on
réussit à se venger sur le pion 17 mai
super jury qui fait vraiment une bonne
partie 1 qu'il faut beaucoup mieux que
ces 1274 ils vont être motivés
on va remettre le feu quatre alors la
sueur qui a valu à 5 du coup on a les
petits cheapos avec prise prise et le
petit flash cet échec qui permettra de
gagner le cavalier sur découverte et
donc on va mettre la pression sur le
cavalier et on va y aller venir
centraliser la dame dans un deuxième
temps remettent notre dame en jeu alors
là encore pas mal joué puisque sur flu
pranger sicile à tout reprendre
allez on va essayer de d'échanger les
pièces et de voir ce que ça donne cette
finale un petit peu technique un petit
peu technique tu vas prendre l'un on va
reprendre
il va prendre on va jouer dame ces trois
dames c3 l'idée c'est de faire une
batterie et de se dire que en cas d'
échange on devrait pouvoir gagner la
finale de fou grâce aux deux contre un
allèle dame
oui là le 2 contre allèles dame il est
il est assez assez assez bon pour pour
nous pour gagner les finales de piétiner
les finales de fou ça se traite plus ou
moins les filles passent et plus les
képis à lecavalier en déça plus des
finales de cavaliers mais ça se traite
plus ou moins comme la finale de roi
alors là il veut mettre le fourbe et si
ça le risque c'est vraiment embêtant
je pense pas je pense que je vais
directement monté le roi je mettrai le
pion à f3 et comme ça je ferai roi des 3
es fou des quatre ce que la finale de
pions et plus facile à gagner la finale
de pièces mineur et je vais gagner un
temps sur le full voyait jeu c'est pour
ça que j'ai laissé venir parce que là il
a un gros problème c'est qu'il peut pas
partir parce qu'elles purent us/asset
qui tombe et s'il reste bas là on va
faire [ __ ] en plus on prend et à 4
donc on a notre miettes de pain en a
quatre le roi noir va être obligé
d'aller chercher le pion à 1 il n'a pas
le choix
et pendant qu'il va de ce côté là bas
nous on va partir par là et on va en
profiter pour faire un peu notre
supermarché sur les pions noirs allaient
droit donc là le roi est très en retard
le roi doit revenir mais il est
il est à la rue maintenant il reste plus
qu'à faire passer le pion h ou n'importe
lequel on va faire passer le pion à
genoux le pion g2 n'est pas dans le
carré de quoi que ce soit donc on va
pousser et on va aller au bout
et là j'aimerais bien quand même que
super juju abandonne un peu dommage je
continue à la joue et va tenter le pat
n'ont même pas été là non je suis là
pour gagner mais bonne partie 1 j'ai pas
très forcément très bien il a très bien
géré et l'ouverture un mieux que moi
d'ailleurs de manière assez étonnante
et finalement c'est pas mal passé on va
réussir à récupérer fab worthy un
deuxième si un deuxième joueur débutant
qui veuille a killer manach propose de
jouer mais bon je le joue déjà dans les
arénas
donc c'est un deuxième joueur amateur
qui veut jouer à les y salue fab salut
salut qu'à ça va ouais ça va je suis en
train de jouer contre contre des
auditeurs là j'ai joué contre super jus
donc bon c'est pas un an bien c'est pas
n'importe quel super juge j'ai faut le
signaler et je suis en train d'assurer
qu père et paulo je propose est donc un
autre peut-être un autre auditeur qui on
attend s'ils veulent s'ils veulent jouer
quoi
ok ok monsieur webb je vais arriver je
veux juste aller voir le chat artal et
de chat mais ils sont pas très actif
pour le moment même à ces inactifs et a
même là les défis a pas vraiment de
défiance qui étonnant quand le préfet de
l'aude soir là le truc pédagogie que
j'avais je sais pas moi c'était ce
n'était pas une liste de défis c'était
fin je sais pas comment appeler ça c'est
un livre de défis donc ce serait cool ce
serait cool or un autre défi le temps
que tout se met en place
conférence à trois d'un web asie vas-y
vas-y et le temps le temps que ça arrive
du coup à voilà un deux roues nouveaux
défis le temps qu'on va être tout ça en
place du coup c'est pas mal de voir les
petites parties lagon gros travail qui
est 791 on peut dire que l'eau pour
20h30
ouais on peut dire paulo pour 20h30
ouais ça tu peux jouer un peu les
parties ont parlé avec le chat et puis
en blu ray le temps qu'ils arrivent
aussi puisque c'est un peu c'est un peu
mou au début mais les gens qui sont qui
sont là ils sont arthur qui demandent ce
qu'on fait black elle en train de jouer
avec les auditeurs
tu vas enfin je sais pas comment on peut
dire à un mur avec qui j'ai parlé il ya
treize minutes
ouais ouais tout petit peu trop grande
et puis du coup ensuite il y aura
toujours qui va passer donc était déjà
die ya trois semaines un mois je publie
il voulait nous parler de la liquiderait
wayne qui tu vas au congo hu et skate
park comme il joue un peu par
correspondance ou quoi il ya des petites
vidéos sur des variantes qui peut être
utilisables par des joueurs amateurs
connaissant le chat est ce qu'ils
peuvent essayer de le poutre et parce
que vraiment une grosse une grosse envie
de poutres h sur ce chat les derniers
temps ah ouais son show ils sont très
chauds ils sont très très chaud ils
veulent poutre et poutres et poutrelles
situe donc est-ce qu'ils pourront tenter
une fois que paul aura montré la
variante dans l'allée quine de poudre a
parlé de voir votre éventail compte pas
jouer la grande mare de liquide veut
défendre son pion et il avait une partie
à l'appui qui m'ont traité comme je t'ai
envoyé d'ailleurs comme ça tu pourras la
copier coller en truelle en fait fait
quand même très très attention parce que
si contre le chat il veut défendre
l'option je pense que le chat en a rien
à [ __ ] vu que les pions c'est de la
merde si tu veux que si je donne dans le
hip hop
monsieur eux dans le chat quand ils font
de quatre cavaliers f6 j'attaque le pion
non je ne veux pas te prendre tu vas
enfin fait voilà je sens mes pièces si
tu veux si tu fais qu'un valet à troyes
le mec te fait au sein qui peut dégager
enfin tu as c'est donc quelque part tu
vois et quand bien même tu fais qu'un
relief 6 e 4 cavaliers assister à ces
trois cavaliers prend 1,4 tu veux
défendre tension je te prends quand même
bon barrett fin tu les connais des
femmes
mais bon voilà ça peut être deux trois
petites idées et puis que ça fait pas de
la grosse théorie et chercher une
nouveauté au 40e coup quoi
ça fait juste un peu plus à apprendre un
peu voire pour jouer quoi pudeur on
réagir en droit de trouver une faille
mais qui sait quoi vous initier pas
pourquoi mais j'ai l'impression qu'on va
la trouver la faille parce que c'est
quoi le truc c'est le 4k relief si c'est
quoi le truc c'est quoi le deuxième coup
bakkali 7,3 tranquille donc en général
on fait des 5 avec les noirs médaille le
e5
bon ben on verra façon peu importe c'est
juste une bande jouable évidemment ça va
pas réfuté les faits pas plutôt joué 5
bah en fait moi je veux bien mais un
joueur des vikings est ce qu'il est
capable quand ils amateurs de connaître
l'opinion de 4,5 et d'aller kiné de tout
quoi s'attendre quand même certaines
cultures sera rejouée 4 5 janvier
niveau son petit truc et du cou
ouais du coup il est tenté de jouer des
5 5 c'est qu'il ya 17 et aient envie de
jouer un truc avec 6 a abandonné c'est
ça c'est ça tu peux faire ça et après
sur cinq peut aussi jouer des quatre vu
quelqu'un ya plein de trucs vachement
que cette partie mais leur ajouté 4 mais
bon peu importe quoi mais vous heureux
cassure des cas tu retrouves dans les
trucs un peu au 8e bouffe ces trois
tubes ou feignent c3 et de salsa retour
un peu m mais du coup est-ce que sur kbc
3 bat chaque des 5 c'est censé être un
bon coup un train c'est peut-être le
meilleur mais aux cinq évidemment c'est
très bien aussi
mais oui ça demande une culture
différente un magret sur tous les fronts
en quoi est ce que tu peux être tenté
alors attends est ce que c'est c'est un
truc de fouine comme ça de jouer
cavalier ses 6 1 au deuxième vois-tu peu
sûres non mais tu comprends le truc quoi
j'avais une fouine totale quoi sur des
cas je veux faire des ae mais bon le
truc c'est qu'il faut une culture de
jouer des trucs avec des ciseaux 6
rebonds en 8 à raison comme un fou c'est
chiant d'être amateur en fait tu peux
rien faire on va t on enfin moi je suis
là j'ai des idées
bon mais c'est vrai que c'est chiant
mais attend voilà je suis en train de ce
que l'on en fait on est en train de
faire un gros gros truc on est en train
d'organiser un match contre lecce ce
bras 1,30 contre ils sont en vente dès
le public ou avec eux le garric que le
public pas de suricates que le public
hockey et on veut faire un 30 contre 30
j'attends la réponse de derrick
ouais mais en gros les mecs j'ai eu du
stade de chess comme il était très chaud
quand ils ont acheté une très bonne idée
il pense que c'est les deux plus grands
clubs
enfin je rajoute je vois pas ce que je
suis un peu à l'américaine quoi mais en
gros ils disent et les deux plus grosses
communautés chess comme tu vois en
dehors des mecs qui ont fait leur club
franz kopf machin club truc mais il
parle en terme de communauté bitstream
5e minute vitrine de communautés de
chaises comme donc au but est de
distribuer communauté de chasse aux rats
il dit que c'est un peu le clash des
titans tu vois bien sûr qu'il faut qu'on
monte en direct du coup bah oui enfin
c'est l'objectif du coup je m'organise
accueilli rico manque de son côté et que
en face à dent contre 30
mais bon de base les mecs sur les
discordes n'ai pas trop compris le truc
tu voyais fonds et maxime lagarde ou
machin mais bon c'est pas la prochaine
c'est quoi leur
c'est que ces communautés domino day 1c
de notre discorde qui doit des marchés
sur le leur ouais c'est ça c'est
discorde ils doivent se marcher dessus
et tout dans le fair-play évidemment et
sans utiliser l'aide de quelconques truc
et c'est sûr va sinon tu perds l'honneur
quoi donc
mais mais mais à ce gros truc qui se
profile j'ai pas de date encore mai
mais j'ai bien envie de poutres et des
suricates way et après de poutrage des
suricates j'ai envie de m'en prendre un
petit du coup tu vois j'avais envie de
passer pour un pour un chevalier c'est à
dire que de base en fait j'ai plutôt
envie de jouer contre les portugais
ouais bah c'est ce qu'on sait tous qu'on
en fait juste ils sont moins nombreux
tous qu'ils sont moins forts donc on va
les poutres et tu vois c'est à de vastes
d'ethias bras moi j'étais pas trop pour
les jouets les coiffes à utiliser mon
papier après au moins dix indirects
champion du monde quoi ouais voilà c'est
ça mais bon ça c'est toi c'est pour
lancer le truc mais après j'ai surtout
très envie de jouer contre des gens
groupes non mais comme la scarpe choisi
nos adversaires on soutenait ne joueront
pas ton reste on garde notre titre
exactement
et donc est donc ça se profile donc
j'attends la réponse d'eric mais je suis
quasi sûr qu'il va accepter parce que
ben il est comme nous il veut faire du
contenu tu vas lui donc ça me ferait
marrer un peu trop bas c'est sûr que ça
fait marrer mais il avait même il était
même allé jusqu'à organiser un match de
chasse bras europe contre chase bras
amérique amérique mais d'aquarelles donc
donc de toutes façons il sera pour ia
killer chess magna qui dit que c'est
juste génial cette idée contre les jazz
bras mais oui c'est fantastique on
pourra inscrire un petit championnat
annuel championnats du monde chez ce
bras contre blitz trine les autres
équipes ne vous intéresse pas nous ne
sommes que deux au monde
et qu'est-ce que je les ai reçus bien
est ce que l'on fait pas de gagner des
lots de mâche un genou qu'il veut non
alors jeune qui veut exactement et on va
juste mettre une limite des lots maximum
à 2300 je pense pour éviter justement
qui aiment bolton et machin que fin
voilà que ça reste un truc amateurs
ouais parce que sinon tu as he tous les
mecs qui ont appelé le pote le matin le
truc dont on veut que ce soit un truc
armateurs amateurs il y aura une limite
basse aussi prenant fin on va avoir avec
eric mais bon dans mon esprit non tu
voies dans le sens où l'objectif c'est
que tout le monde puisse participer
bah oui mais quand on trace en contre
sens qu'au final
oui oui on peut mettre on peut mettre
des limites en fait c'est en plus c'est
pas le truc duchess comme je vais te
montrer d'ailleurs total partage tatin
d'où tiens j'ai pas le partage mais
c'est un outil qui te permet de mettre
limite minimum et limite maximum
joueur du genre on peut dire 30 minimum
mais maximum 100 c'est à dire que s'il
ya soixante dix mecs de leur équipe et
que 40 de notre côté ce sera du quart en
compte 40 tu vois mais j'arrête on peut
tu vois j'ai réglé ce n'est pas encore
fait ouais donc voyez non mais ça peut
être cool ça peut bien mais ça va être
très très cool comme match et puis il ya
le suricate il sera chaud avec sa
musique techno son machin tu vois mais
justement pas oui oui nous allons les
flocons paris dans la gueule dégage ses
arêtes avec la techno de merde c'est
d'emmener le ventoux sera quand bon vous
ne sais pas mais c'est en projet
j'imagine oui mais je le découvre - bah
je sais même pas encore j'ai écrit hier
à j'ai écrit hier à eric j'aime écrire à
eric je suis là à bon est-ce qu'il a
peur tu vois là du coup est ce qu'il est
en train de se dire et comme bolton déjà
kiev dans l'arena bon il a pas fini une
fois derrière toi est ce que nous ça va
suffire tu as faim non mais je suis très
content de ce truc là dr femmes deux
hommes de 2 à bénir des bolton jamais ça
c'est rare que jamais en fait c'est
enfin fou je sais le truc quand il n'y a
pas erick tu sais que les chaises rails
sont derrière quoi du coup ce que tu as
fait le punch line quoi mais si j'avais
fait la dernière fois
voilà peut être la barbe barre de
hipster de mer dégage dégage avec ta
mère mais elle va peut-être qu'ils
remettent la barbe non mais bon d'araser
quand il finit devant toi au tournoi qui
la rendra plus jamais mais un qui me
fait particulièrement fier dans ses
arénas
mais quand je dis chier c'est vraiment
chier au sens premier du terme c'est
mayer un peu chiant bail mais je vais
dire j'en ai marre quoi enfin pourquoi
tu as le droit de jouer ce tournoi en
fait les stream en même temps plus bas
oui mais gère ton stream enfin moi je
vais faire une limite quoi situe à moins
de 100 personnes sur ton stream tutu ne
participe pas aux prix dégage ça ne
m'intéresse pas non mais le mec il est
fort enfin j'en ai marre hier j'étais
gagne encore contre lui une fois et il
m'arnaquer
j'en ai marre j'en peux plus j'ai fait
un sacrifice de dames de folie et tout
mais le mec non il est trop fort et en
plus il me trois femmes maintenant mais
il est gentil en suisse après la partie
il m'écrit reparti il fut pleine de
qinghai schiste irwin tu vas faire le
mec était très content de ma partie ce
que j'ai fait un sacrifice de dames il
était très heureux mais j'arrive à pas
compris mon esprit quand je fais des
arénas king c'est à dire que je suis là
pour me fout de ta gueule de base donc
s'agir le mec me parle d'échec quoi là
bas il est pas dans l'esprit mais bon je
suis complètement raide la joue contre
un mec à 13,70 suis en train de faire
défoncer non il va devenir de plus en
plus foi en quoi césarienne hacking ses
meilleurs rôles que jouent souvent là à
bijoux tout le temps j'en peux plus là
j'aurais pu perdre une pièce par des 4 2
fois 1 les mecs de quel droit mais j'en
peux plus il ya hammer bonds and her
franchement je suis quasi toujours
devant lui un bon choix oui mais bon
aujourd'hui c'est les mecs étaient pas
contents sûr sur youtube
parce que tu ai je dit aux mecs pendant
le stream et où tu pouvais te consulter
que 2630 film déjà de base dont tu te
tais toi ça va toi si tu as le toi je te
gère quoi y'a un mec qui m'écrit sûr sur
youtube unis les mecs sont quand même
plus fort que toi
fermez là mais j'ai même écrit un
systran et ça fait marrer en fait c'est
à dire ça je chante qu'on fera une farce
et second degrés ces derniers passent
pas toujours facile un second degré sur
internet c'est comme quand relais des
sorties se régler mon peu importe et
donc à lui mais tant qu'il ya des
appariements mais il a eu des
appariements de cocu c'était un maître
international américain un jeune un
gamin il est passé au travers des
gouttes
non mais ok mais j'en ai marre enfin les
mecs ne joue personne du tournoi face si
tu n'as pas le droit qui gère moi un
moment donné j'enchaîne meilleur mérite
hirian meilleur tu vois trois round
d'affilée tu as faim fou tu rajoutes
celle du tout pour avoir le strike
peuvent aussi le quoi aller danser c'est
très compliqué là tu vois là tu es là tu
dis tu as même magnus la lituanie la un
peu la goutte d'eau quand même pour
gagner le strict ignifuges sais pas si
simple là parce que je m'affaire nul et
donc j'ai vu ça comme truc de merde j'ai
eu quoi d'autres non mais après j'ai
enchaîné j'ai rejoué le maître fide
espagnols deux fois j'ai joué à man
enfin quand jouer des mecs mon titre et
c'est des mecs qui étaient 23 40 sur une
chaise comme pas de joie j'ai commencé
le tournoi à 20 à 2005 j'ai fini à 2516
tu as faim fou oui oui et puis c'est dur
dans ces trois là parce que tout plein
de mecs qui te rapporte 0 point et
et du coup et du coup je fini derrière
meilleur fini derrière donc ce mec là
qui a eu la chance est troisième c'est
qui qui a fait 3e de shanklin à la
chambre latence expire le 3 mai et
crypto de chasse c'est lui c'est tête
hammer qui a finit finalement devant moi
ouais c'est hammer qui a fini devant moi
en fait je me goure c'est quoi son
pseudo bmj a élevé je vais en mettre
jeunes ligue amr est devant nous et du
cou et du coup j'ai fini de l'ariège
krikor qui d'habitude est ma bête noire
normal je suis toujours d afrique or et
devant un murray l'un des leurs devant
mais faut que tu me prépares contre
krikor j'en peux plus j'en ai plein les
couilles de ces ouvertures chance
non mais j'en peux plus on présume dix
banques voilà de quoi il en retourne
combat partout c'est à dire que je vais
te montrer après c'est une station d'alt
en bout alors quant au lot arrive on en
parlera à quoi ça sera le début sera
préparation contre mérité rial non mais
j'en peux plus c'est à dire que le mec
j'ai pas une bonne j'ai pas une position
que je joue bien dans l'ouverture jamais
à touba darou apollon l'appel après
après celui de soi ouais ouais ouais bon
oeil à ces chiens mais j'en ai marre je
suis malade je m'autorise graves dont un
peu trop dire non mais méritait rien ça
devient un problème et c'est aussi pour
ça que j'ai envie de le châtier de
châtier sa communauté quoi les portugais
ouais on va aller défoncer cette
fantastique c'est un carnage un message
est un carnage c'est à dire cds
portugais brésilien les mecs ils seront
même plus si son président portugais à
la fin c'était parti non moi je ne sais
plus quoi je suis nicaraguayen tient du
off
excuse moi mais oui une en valais on va
aller on va les poutres et c'est vers ça
va être un massacre d'art ils se sont
fait un speech est championship
brésilien oui c'est bien moi c'est bien
ouais beaucoup plus intéressant que le
championnat de france or c'est du coup
puisque les meilleurs joueurs qui
participent là tous
ouais ouais bon de voir ça c'est pas si
mal mais ça qui anime veulent ni etienne
déjà ça fait mal proche m france et puis
à ta question calme bon genre de rapides
à part en main
de quel droit quoi et pas par moi
surtout qu'on met du coup comment t'as
pas jouer finalement moi je voulais le
commenter de base
bon après j'ai pas eu les pgm je te
rassure ça serait très compliqué ça même
commenté gratuitement tu vois c'est
sympa alors pour le coup et je sais que
maxime a mal joué
lagarde la merde me disais que
j'aimerais aussi mal tout seul
mais même quand il était né coûts et du
coup que j'ai un regard d'un poste au
sommet inédit vous la de vlad foetus
mort est battu et là tu es dinars maxime
même à ton meilleur niveau
vlad foetus ban mê mais du coup il a
quoi il ay là il a quatre sur quatre
voilà en fait juste battu les mets quand
jean supervalu je sais pas quand le site
du championnat je regarde et a du coup
marc garde après on prend paulo allez on
regarde on prend paul pasqualini 20h30
on y va quand même l'avoir générer des
clés mais je paye blanc direct quand je
rate carrément c'est quoi c'est le
rapide où c'est le blitz c'est le rapid
ajouta du rapide on en est un
en y ajoutant les fans des ricains ils
en sont ils en sont à styron de jouer
alors bye à jules en tête 6 sur 6 quand
même ça tu joues bien deuxième avec cinq
et demi sur une flopée ya fraysse ya
jean pierre leroux corner tommaso doux
air asu pavlidis je sais pas malgré 10
voilà alors y'a koval colenco qui a cinq
personnes cinq cheikhs et chefs 5
igor bogdanoff 5 guliyev 5 un match
produit par cinq
fedor choc 5 bon ils sont pleins cinq
roquettes bon et alors la garde c'est
quand même assez fort lagardere et tu
regardes 20 56e arrivée soit 56e
il a gagné le ronde à un élan de la
rivière en 3 il a perdu la 4e battaglini
ah oui j'ai pas mal bataille en plus il
suit les stream qui s'appelle maintenant
flom mais c'est ça une personne déloyale
oui ça fait quand même très attention
parce que c'est un suiveur d'esprit donc
automatiquement jeu vers sa défaite faut
qu'il fasse comme très attention à ce
qui les regarde c'est une défaite
logique une veine doji contre un contre
un contre un auditeur bitstream bon donc
rien de choquant et après perdu contre
anatole de la chose avait lui aussi il
suit la chaîne je crois donc oui j'ai
regardé donc toute défaite logique oif
voilà c'est après il a battu un joueur à
10 800 m à 4 m de joueurs il ya
sentinelle il ya d'alimenter aussi il ya
des joueurs à 4 jean-noël bahia et
gabriel aussi breaking bad et j'ai du
mal à l'appeler flambées sont tellement
parce que ma vie appelé battaglini mais
bon on va faire les choix sérieux 4 si
ça me rappelle un peu mon pays talib
étoiles du coup tu viens quand à cannes
sekkat attaqué lui vient en fait un bon
jour
moi je reste est énorme et si mais oui
mais justement c'est quand un bail à
leur rapide francophonie je sais plus
qui faisait le 12 ou 13 ou par les
13-14-15 peut-être et l'open gonfle au
16 mai 16 au 23
c'est un truc comme ça les a fait
sourire moi j'ai des copains qui arrive
le 22 je serai un peu là donc on après
on va faire on va faire pareil le truc
quoi mais tu restes à prime tu restes tu
vas tu ne sais pas encore tu n'as aucune
aucun aucun aucun opinion qua non je
peux dominer ou tu restes avant on en
fait j'ai rien compris ce que tu vas
mais en fait je voulais arriver
soit je reste avant si pressée maso qui
il reste aussi pas qu'il y avait en plus
en avance ouais sinon j'ai pas venir
tout seul ou un truc et après je peux
rester un peu pourquoi pas quelques
jours voilà voir tout ça va être la
folie là en fait après à partir du 22 22
j'ai des potes qui arrive c'est ils sont
très très chaud je me dis tout de suite
c'est pas des majorettes ils sont russes
ouais j'avais déjà déjà csf ça et c'est
mon 2 et s'est qualifié en quoi ces
riffs ils sont là quoi mais mais du coup
c'est plutôt accéléré comme autant de
rencontres de championnat de france ne
s'est pas accélérée
non non ça se parle doucement et puis
voilà comment fêter a trop de joueurs
c'est pas mal d'arrivées de faire des
quarts de finale demi finale mais a trop
de joueurs provenant à 8 ça
et à trop de joueurs alors est ce
simplement de gagner de gagner l'open
data dac
déjà c'est fini non mais ils peur sinon
il reste quoi rendre demain matin et
après ça commence les trucs mais il ya
trop de joueurs il peut être accéléré
mais bien sûr il ya beaucoup trop de
joueurs et c'est trop la loterie quoi dû
énormément va pas demander pourquoi en
fait si tu veux j'aime bien l'esprit
coupe tu vois à la fin mais moi je
verrais vraiment ça comme tu sais data
verte dans les bonnes nouvelles
le speech à cette année oui déjà bon ça
aura de nouveau lieu très important
et deuxièmement ils ont retenu les
erreurs du passé et un petit peu ce
qu'on avait dit donc ça je suis très
très heureux c'est à dire que tu vas tu
vas avoir des mecs qui vont s'éliminer
au début et elle est tête de série
rendre qu'à la fin quoi et je veux dire
par là que là ce serait pas mal je sais
pas tu as quatre mecs qui serait
directement enfin admettons deux mc
qu'ils soient déjà en 2000 genre mvl et
paquereau où je sais pas où déjà en
quarts tu vois mais qu'ils soient
protégés qui est qu'à venir à la fin tu
vois et les eaux damas qui se qualifie
avec moins de mecs ça c'est un peu le
système tennis finalement 2 1 on revient
à la même chose d'être d'austérité même
en coupe de la ligue au foot
en fait dans tous les sports enfin viser
c'est ça qui est fort comme était déjà
que c'est que même quand tu veut copier
c'est même copié ce n'est pas évident
cieux c'est à dire qu'il faudrait un
label made in china pour les échecs
messieurs vous de chasse que made in
china manon ils ont réussi finalement ce
franchement t'as des trucs chinois était
sur le cul oui et toi tu comprends
l'imaginer le wanted
il est fantastique se dit le bois de
classe ils viennent que six jetons qui
sortent mais il va être fantastique
lowan place 6 ils ont alors engagé une
autre excellente nouvelle
excuse moi on me dit la nouvelle aude
comme l'a dit autre excellente nouvelle
de sébastien joachim écrit que et anne
saga donc bon le mec suis quand même la
chaîne quotidiennement il a tout le
temps sur le stream voilà les joints
rapide il a fini premiers jeunes et
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est
sébastien joie qui a fini premier et
sylvain qui a fini troisième don qui dit
on est partout quoi tu me laisses crime
de bol c'est ce qui m'a dit le lion
nouveaux talents on a tous ratés quoi
donc pour bientôt les t-shirts le club
tous
non mais là c'est fantastique c'est à
dire que les mecs sont pas les ars et
ils sont allés razr notre tournoi en
force soit très très bien on est clair
pour leur dire on appelle polonais
attend il faut que je le rejoigne à la
conférence je pense comme on veut il
faut joindre à la conférence fait
longtemps qu'on se marche un truc mais
ce que j'entends plus comment je fais
franchement d'une conférence récupérer
la particule m'angoisse gélas m on va
essayer d'aller ferait chuter pause
bon je sais pas si on attend point bas
voilà je conviens bart sonner chez paul
tard à temps jetez plus et je tu étais
encore la halle au polo wee aa salle est
bon pour la marche
sao paulo oui ou non on est très chaud
pour te réfuté en fait on est là à aa
si tu veux j'ai quatre ordinateurs qui
tournent autour de moi ils sont sûrs
stockfisch 12 avec des ordis de la nasa
jeu si tu veux je suis chaud quoi
évidemment évidemment alors par contre
il ya un décalage dans le show c'est
normal est-ce que tu regardes le stream
en même temps ouais je regarde losc en
mai pendant ces longues c'est pour ça
faut que tu coupes le stream très
important je me trompe pas à l'eau wen a
toujours là ouais je suis plus vollard
et les bas normandes la plus décalage
est ce que le partage d'écran attentant
kevin vous montrer cette vidéo c'est ça
pour acter plaisait bah ouais voilà ok
c'est bon tu voudras l'échiquier on voit
les fonds de kevin en fait voilà vous
voyez mon écran fait voilà et du coup
parce que moi je suis je suis un vieux
dinosaures vois ça va venir
alors attendre à ce qu on appelle vidéo
de groupe c'est quoi c'est gratuit c'est
fermé ses ballades façon je crois que
mon bien dans l'appel mais on est là on
est dans l'appel le groupe fiat à turin
à faire ça tu te calmes sur l'écran et
c'est 30 centimes la minute et du
tableau donc on va prix d'ami prix d'ami
prix d'ami prix d'ami après fait
attention de bien déconnecté l'appel tu
as des voix ya des gens qui truquent
restent ouverts c'est un peu comme les
pièces téléphoniques et mec tu appelles
il tonné une fois le téléphone et tulle
et rappelle ses numéros payants je peste
c'était déjà arrivé
non non non non je vais je me suis comme
ça je supprime tout moi je suis je suis
comme ma grand mère tu vois on ne me
donne pas non toutes les nouvelles
technologies
est-ce que vous est ce que vous voulez
une anecdote une anecdote sur l'ad une
récente alors une anecdote qui date d'il
ya quatre cinq ans à un moment donné il
ya à moscou il ya eu un piège à ok faut
savoir qu'à moscou tu peut recharger ton
téléphone dans des genres de machines
automatiques qui ressemble un peu à des
bancomat où tu vas mettre tout nu mais
tu vas re écrire ton numéro de téléphone
tu vas mettre un billet dedans et ça va
mettre du crédit sur son téléphone
ce crédit va te servir soit appelée soit
faire des achats en fait même faire des
achats en ligne avec du crédit de
téléphone donc donc il ya des idiots qui
se met à envoyer des sms qu'ils disent
et moi je me marre avec ma femme il en
tient encore un idiot qui écrit je sais
pas salut j'ai je suis dans une
situation très compliquée j'ai
absolument que besoin que tu mettes 30
euros sur mon téléphone je t'explique
après est ici avec un prénom je sais pas
par exemple fab pour prendre un prénom
qu'on ne voit normalement tu te mars que
c'est un numéro que tu connais pas et le
message est très neutre et bonfim tkm
courant larnaca bon il ya un moment vlad
est tombé dans cette arnaque
je t'assure et en fait c'est hyper
marrant c'est que cette histoire est un
peuple est avec moi parce que du coup
c'est ce message avec le prénom lna et
moi ils pouvaient pas me joindre si
j'étais en train de faire un truc il a
mis de l'argent sur les téléphones et
après justin c'est juste le truc des de
l'appel avec paulo ça m'a fait penser à
ça de l'appel payant mais donc c'était
un piège qui arrive assez souvent et
même les meilleurs sont tombés dedans
quoi donc le piège
je pensais que c'était un piège là c'est
ridicule et puis finalement tu vois
cette histoire laisse à penser que
c'était un piège très sophistiqué qua
non mais faut il a plein d'argent
c'est la différence entre le progrès et
la modernité
ouais mais après après le truc d'avoir
la possibilité de recharger le téléphone
dans des bancomats t du coup de payer
que ce que tu consommes
et ça c'est vraiment cool quoi non mais
je dis ça parce que je suis très en
colère en fait il ya une semaine ou deux
semaines je ne sais plus j'ai entendu
sur l'une des radios en suisse où je
travaille sur la toile et la vidéo là
dans le football qui sort elle est là
aux massues c'est moderne
tu vois en gros si t'es pas contre la
vidéo c'est que ce n'est pas quelqu'un
de moderne ce n'est pas pour la vidéo
c'est que c'est ptet pas moderne ce qui
est un argument évidemment fallacieuse
fallacieux qui ne veut strictement rien
dire
donc c'est pour ça donc c'est pour à
tous les gens qui me disent c'est
moderne tu veux c'est moi ça me va me va
pas dire c'est bien pourtant voilà ces
voix là mais ça va évaluer ça va évoluer
la vidéo foot ça va devenir bien il faut
il alors dit non l'a fait là celle et
macvin culte qui parlent presque pas
l'histoire du football
on en revient à l'autre b bat à trois
semaines non mais c'est sûr mais on en
reparlera dans deux trois ans quatre ans
cinq ans au rugby savent ça finit par
être bien ça me longtemps mais c'est
bien maintenant un a strictement rien à
voir c'est comme les statistiques le
foot n'est pas mobilisables
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il est
difficile à comprendre et derrière en
plus toute cette nouvelle technologie
qui arrive n'oublie pas tes une
idéologie anglo saxon qui fait on
importe des manières de consommer le
sport aux états unis eau et la porte en
europe et ont créé que le sport européen
doivent s'adapter à une mentalité anglo
saxon qui n'est pas du tout bénéfique
pour le sport mais c'est pas grave
continuons comme ça c'est moderne non
mais je sais juste qu'ils savent pas
l'utiliser et qu'ils vivaient ils
veulent avec sa sphère de la perfection
et parfois ça n'a strictement rien à
voir c'est pas une question ne pas
savoir l'utiliser si tu utilises la vie
des otages amène à jamais la main de
maradona en 1986 est à jamais son
deuxième but derrière
sauf que derrière la main de maradona la
fameuse main de dieu tu as toute
l'histoire des relations entre
l'argentine et l'angleterre à l'époque
avec la guerre des malouines
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça mais
c'est pas grave faisons un sport où
justement il ya plus d'émotions ya plus
de sentiments n'ayant qu'une vision
analytique
non mais regardez au tennis a bien
marché aussi finalement ce sont pas les
mêmes fort ce ne sont pas les bonnes et
sport le football c'est un sport pour
les voyous
vous comprendrez ça vous comprendrez ce
que c'est que la nature du sport et de
la nature du football
ouais possible c'est pas mes mails j'ai
du mal à te dire parce que c'est vrai
que je regarde très peu de football soit
je consomme pas beaucoup de fatou la
bière est bon donc donc bye comme je
consomme plus de rugby et tennis tu as
et des sports où la vidéo c'est bien
implanté donc du coup c'est c'était pour
ça mais ça et qu'au rugby c'est plus un
sport c'est plus un port aristocrate en
fait historiquement le rugby ouais enfin
le football a été créée aussi par les
aristocratie anglaise mais ce qu'il est
dans sa nature est très différente mais
tu sais c'est un débat qu'on ait ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que les gens
qui sont contre la vidéo en fait sont
comme par hasard des gens qui
réfléchissent et un petit peu et en fait
tous les gens qui sont pour la vidéo
sont souvent des gens qui veulent juste
faire de l'argent et c'est très
intéressant
ce débat là mais du coup c'est un simple
c'est dans la par exemple la coup du
monde y aura la vidéo ou pas parce que
j'ai pas suivi enfin il se mettre mais
ça c'est un peu étrange quand même ne
pas l'avoir testé de la main dit
récemment je pense que c'est une
mauvaise idée personnellement non mais
c'est une catastrophe moi ça fait un an
que je la vis en bundesliga tu vois ça
fait un an que je vois que ça fait les
dégâts tout à fait en pâtir l'évolution
du sport et ce qui fait que des grands
champions un peu partout dans le monde
sont en train de dire on est juste en
train de tuer jean paul ii tuer notre
façon du football pour l'adapter arias
mène des universitaires qui ont beaucoup
travaillé dessus je vais pas faire de
politique mais si tu veux c'est aussi un
maître la vidéo si tu fais un peu de
d'irrationnel ça permet aussi aux
bourgeois de s'intéresser au football
donnent l'impression tout comprendre
il ya beaucoup de textes ont été écrits
latine mais c'est pas grave mais mais
mais du goût du coup le truc bien quand
ils ont fait évoluer le truc au rugby
c'est qu'au début au rugby's avait
l'objectif avec la vidéo de trouver
vraiment la vérité tu as l'air de savoir
s'ils avaient essayé ou pas et tout ça
et du coup ils ont abandonné ce truc là
et c'est ça s'est beaucoup mieux passé
une moment où ils ont
où ils ont abandonné sa et où ils ont
laissé quand même larbitre reste quand
même au centre et ses suivants comment
il pose les questions et suivants
suivant son ressenti en fait la vidéo
elle va plutôt l'aider à orienter sa
décision de base quoi
oui moi ce qui me fait rigoler dans tous
ces débats commencés que ces débats qui
existait déjà au xviiie siècle
tu me rappelles le scientisme c'est une
façon scientifique de vouloir gérer
l'humanité c'est fabuleux ça enlève
toute l'émotion mais c'est pas grave moi
j'ai bientôt 50 ans ouais ouais après
après c'est ce que jusque là là là où je
veux bien concevoir c'est que ça dépend
ça dépend vraiment des sports et ça
dépend ça dépend de beaucoup de choses
voilà ça dépend beaucoup de choses mais
bon ça va arriver on verra bien ce que
ça donne on en reparlera dans quatre
cinq ans on verra bien au niveau de
toute façon tu peux pas arrêter un match
pendant cinq minutes comme il m'en est
quelquefois j'ai vu des matches avec des
vidéos j'en ai vu un an voire deux et
c'est insupportable parce que tu passes
le ralenti et tu vois pas vraiment bien
avec les caméras si le joueur a vraiment
touché ou pas et finalement perso pour
le moment je ne garderai que pour leur
jeu en fait la vidéo et pour leur moteur
en marche moi c'est parfait
il ya toujours faute le sochaux ce jeu
réclame faute et donc il ya tout eu peut
toujours revenir plutôt à une faute mais
dès qu'il va dire mais pourquoi que le
pas là parce qu'en fait une au cycle des
choses qui sont flagrants mais ça te
donne un sentiment de vérité c'est
complètement faux si le kadima dijon
avant il a mis un petit tacle un à un
joueur et que l'article ne siffle pas
mais c'est celle unis et par quoi que
juste intéressé d'un penalty ou pas ne
sait pas faire un message enlèverait
pour le penalty moi je laisserais
vraiment que pour
que pour le que pour leur jeu en fait ce
que pour la ligne de hors jeu m'en
serais une règle qui est qui est facile
à gérer et qui est assez facile à
revenir et aurait même pas besoin
d'appel vidéo tu aurais que le mec
devant la caméra qui regardent ces
laveurs joue pas il faut que ce soit
comme au rugby hors jeu clair et évident
savent que si c'est un quart de vin qui
dépasse il n'y a pas on laisse
l'appréciation de basse quoi clair et
évident il ya un an n'a perdu aucune
chaîne de foot avait complètement mais
complètement c'est une chaîne de foot
majeur c'est ça se voir d'ailleurs là on
a un petit terrain de foot un séjour
s'est empressé vert voilà des joueurs
vas-y bien sûr ils vont ils font ce
qu'ils valent du coup toi tu veux parler
de la liquider nous vous les réfuter ton
ami qui du coup on était choquant juge
rappelé la philosophie que j'ai en fait
c'est que moi je cherche à jouer en tant
qu'amateur et donc je peux proposer
entre guillemets des petites variantes à
des amateurs
juste pour avoir l'impression de se
développer tranquillement et non pas
d'avoir une vérité apps donc c'est une
vanne que j'ai pratiqué dans mes jeunes
années
j'ai remarqué qu'ils avaient pris très
populaire par exemple sur sur internet
quand les blancs quand les blancs jouent
et donc c'est la banque qui avait laissé
trois donc psychologiquement l'idée au
passage très simple c'est que les gars
qui jouent là les lignes se prépare
toujours avec leurs variantes avec le
sac et la bomba non tu l'as tu leur dis
par écouter non je vais faire cavaler
c'est pour bloquer donc traîné sa
attends je vais bien montrer ferait tout
le monde comprenne c'est eux quatre
cavaliers m6 et l'ouverture à li qin
damman donc l'idée c'est de manger les
poules de quatre voilà d'habitude on
pousse en vingt cinq pour attaquer le
cavalier gagner du temps dessus
ok donc l'idée des noirs en fait femme
tu corriges cij est armé c'est de
laisser les blancs prendre de l'espace
au centre et puis de contre attaquer
voilà d'essayer de les faire trop
poussée qui serait un peu de faiblesse
pour plus tard les rames à cette même
voix la loi scellier de fond quoi dire
et en fait ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que pourquoi est ce que j'aime
beaucoup cette variante avec les blancs
c'est aussi j'en avais parlé avec
avec fabien il ya quelques semaines
c'est que moi j'avais lu des bouquins
dans les années 80-90 kit expliqué
qu'ils te donnerai des explications sur
des variantes ou les blancs n'avaient
pas davantage mais où les noirs avaient
des problèmes
voilà en gros tu joues soit pour le bien
soit pour la nul avec les blancs donc je
pense qu'au départ c'est pas mal et
c'est plus jouer un jour plus fort que
toi et bat tapoter 7,7 minimes que je
vous proposais qui permet peut-être j'ai
envie de dire au minimum d'avoir une
nulle n'ont pas assuré évidemment parce
qu'on fait plus lourd des erreurs mais
relativement faciles à comprendre et à
jouer est juste de saluer les rockets
n'ont qu'à y ses trois oncles et noir
ils ont ils ont quand même option en
gros soit plus jurer à lorsque le
problème c'est quand tu joues la victime
tu te dis que le gars va pas forcément
te jouer aux 5
tu vois parce que sinon ça revient
d'être les maps 4,5 et sur quoi tu
pourrais jouer poussé 4 par exemple on
sait qu'à tout cas ya trois ou que je
vois une telle boîte avec f 4g croit ou
non mais tu joues une ouverture avec 4,5
et d'ailleurs pour nous les gens qui ont
suivi répertoire on peut faire caler f3
et carrière froide en écaille c6 des
quatre et ça retombe dans une écossaise
quatre carrés d alors ça c'est un peu le
truc dont on parlait ce matin
oui c'est que dans cette position là il
ya quand même pas mal d'options pour les
noirs malheureusement de schiste au
québec à gilly d'or et fourbe et 4 1 il
faut bien qu'un choix que c est réputé
pour être le plus cher de cette position
non moi je trouve ça va pour les blancs
rouges prend 2,5 en fait disons petit
racle est faux de fouet donné tu reviens
qu'à l'ailé droite par les ingrédients
restent dans le tour est vite fait c'est
comme une berlinoise couleurs inversées
mais on a des tas en plus vous prend ces
trois il faut faire on prend deux des
quais les points 4e tir ac et en vo si
les normes avec des cinq on croit qu'ils
avaient des f4 m'attaque le pion et on
fera ce t4 un jour pour cendres et les
pions doublé et on va essayer de jouer
avec un petit avantage avec la perte de
chou et s'ils font plus des six barres
en plus quand même toute façon battre
cagliari 4 10 m le plan c est exact
enfer b3 à b2
une partie quoi passer pour moi du coup
on pourra peut-être faire aimer bon mais
du bout mais du coup ils peuvent pas
être faire caillasser 6 peuvent se faire
dès six voix les sables ou pas
d'ailleurs ça me dit rien je sais pas
voulu faire une mine et que c'est avec
un temps de moins n'a pas marché on a
perdu sa mère doute mais bon je pense
hélas est douteux mais à voir mais bon
que c'est vrai après tango ce qu'on dise
avant est ce que peut lui aussi c'est
que votre avec les jardins liqin surtout
au niveau amateur ils sont pas censés
aussi pouvoir jouer aussi bien et
liquent inc e45 qu'autre chose bien sûr
tout ça les fortes à travailler ça des
forces à travailler d'autres cliniques
qui n'ont pas forcément envie de
travailler quoi on a presque envie de
jouer ou 14,5
lorsqu'on a caressé trois en phase donc
c'était un peu compliqué alors l'autre
possibilité je pense cédé 6 évidemment
après ça les mecs qui sont très très
dans l'esprit paulo bas ils sont
tellement dans l'esprit tu défends ton
pions je te prends quand même
oui mais voilà elles les ont fait une
pièce de plus mais mais voilà bon mais
eux normalement tu les bas quand même ça
je pense que je dois même si les numéros
de fatigue
ces dernières années je pense que je
dois pouvoir y arriver pendant que kate
a pas peur des mecs qui sont très dans
l'esprit qui te disent tu protèges
champions je te prends quand même ça ne
ramènera des six oui donc des six
évidemment et douala convient si on est
un peu dans le même schéma que 4 5 c'est
à dire que le gars bah tu joues des
cartes la tuerie de radium pirc voilà tu
reprends une pierre donc le mec à ce
qu'il a envie de se coltiner les marins
de la pire ou un simple par exemple dans
le cadre de figure avec par exemple la
finale en d'amour trois tranches c'est
un exemple c'est repoussé 4006 franc qui
est très intéressant à jouer à fond pour
les noirs d'air c'est une variante comme
ça ou alors comme vous l'avez dit une
vraie pire qu on s'est regardé une
partie de bulles coderre de quoi on
trouve deux contres radjabov je pense
radjabov dulko
ou alors évidemment de jouer comme on
parlait tout à l'heure de l'apda
philidor de très bien jouer kf3 la ci
répondent pas j'aurai finalement
pourquoi je vous la finale tu reviens de
votre fils d'or c'est laurent qui sait
peut-être même meilleur un dr femmes
moi je joue plutôt que des fraudeurs tu
mens seine-et-marne d'opposition l'arrêt
après la finale b en fait ça dépend
compte qu'ils jugent aussi si tu peux
aller par mois je vais jetter
internationale comme jazz band mauvaise
escient j'ai fait j'ai fait nul sans
trop de problèmes et blanc quoi bon si
je joue j'ai vraiment envie de gagner je
vais plutôt je qualifie 3 est-ce qu'on
veut voir un truc un peu bizarre de la
reprise prise sous g5
mais je crois que c'est juste après dame
prend des buts mais ici j'ai jamais vu
mais peut-être c'est possible mais dan
prandelli trois produits touchés 5 c'est
une des rares de chine
je pense aussi soit logique d'ailleurs
dans le même style de trucs vu qu'on
parle de ça dans les mêmes styles de
finale un peu bizarre et à sa là je
reviens tout au début mais c'est pour
pouvoir élargir un peu mais un tas
s'attend à celle là aussi toi tu la
connais femmes et la salle elle est
carrément pas mal pour les noirs d'après
ce que je vaux et même à l'autre tu peux
aller tu peux excuser moi enfin bien
dangereux il ya même des quatre des six
t4 5
c'est très très bien pour les pour les
noirs est ici juste à titre informatif
le mieux pour les blancs tu avais un peu
utilisé ces cavaliers f3 cavaliers b17
pour protéger cavaliers g53 huit
cavaliers b5 et fous des six épreuves
comme ça et en fait ça va pour les
blancs en réalité ce serait étonnant
qu'il soit perdant coaching ou quoi non
mais c'est juste c'est passé rien en
fait ce matin la paire de fou mais d'un
autre côté et noir vont bien vite mettre
laurent recettes ramener le fou en
russie c'est ça va aller pour les noirs
aussi un septet du froid des cinq ouais
mais juste pour dire que si jamais vous
faites piéger d'enfin signalement vous
propose cette finale en fait ben moi
j'ai gagné une partie comme ça y'a pas
si longtemps en longues et en fait après
ça si jamais tu connais pas ce plan avec
les blancs c'est juste un peu moins bien
par contre bon en fait le truc c'est que
ces structures à mieux pour les noirs
agouazi fiancée catherine et donc ça
arrive bana couleurs comme ça où
couleurs inversées quand on vous dit si
tu y viennent ça peut arriver mais tu as
des céciliennes jean saint leu 4 c 5
imagine que les blancs jouent des
petites variantes même des trois on va
dire tiens et si les noirs font dessins
etc et que tu fais pas en c3 c'est pas
bon dieu dans le premier reprend dès 1
600 cd bonne finale probablement être
étalée même chose dans l'anglais c'est
vrai exactement c'est tous les mêmes
trucs ouais on est tout à fait dans
entre guillemets ma philosophie avec les
blancs des ouvertures ou les blancs
n'ont pas forcément davantage les noirs
des problèmes la peta est ce qu'il faut
une petite précision les noirs et là ils
sont pas bien même c'est très bien plus
c'est vraiment devenu un peu je pense
même la philosophie est la carlsson ce
chercheur amateur depuis les mêmes au
dessus
c'est très très c'est très intéressant
de jouer comme ça c'est à dire que tu
joues pour deux résultats seulement oui
mais pourquoi tu essayes de jeu pour
deux raisons non mais tu joues pour de
résultats et emmené tu donnes justin
caisse en un coup quoi et tu te dis pas
de chance coiffe un nom mais c'est ça en
plus c'est horrible mais c'est le sait
vraiment plus c'est que souvent tu
penses vue pour des résultats était un
moine je suis une erreur signé comment
je peux être aussi nul quoi pas la
première fois ça vous arrivez à tous les
deux ans j'imagine
non moi ça m'arrive tout le temps mais
mais géré par là même à vous comme un
fouet à tout le monde
non mais ça me rappelle c'est très
intéressant
ça me rappelle une vieille partie écoute
en 2000 ou encore là je suis dans le
cliché complet je rends compte 1 2101
jeune asiatique et donc je me suis dit
ah bah forcément c'est un art soit dans
les clichés complaire c'est un asiatique
forcément ça doit être un grand
tacticien et voui
il avait 16 ans j'ai pu quoi et je veux
tu dis c'est encore un joueur de
grünfeld eh bien je lui ai fait la
finale qu'on a fait tout à l'heure car
yves paccalet 6 et 4 g ici qu'elles se
croient des saints s'est prononcée prend
1,4 et puis on les joue moi je vais
jouer ça et comme par hasard
stratégiquement il n'avait pas les
il n'avait pas joué en tout cas c était
assez bien fort mais il m'a joué c'est
ça et j'ai gagné cette finale assez
facilement et à la fin de la partie je
me dis mais elle est où mon erreur et il
n'y a pas dit non mais comme le jus
comme si tu veux les je suis quelqu'un
de très politique et je lui dis pas non
mais c'est peut-être le schéma tout
simplement quoi donc le guettaient dans
ses schémas je joue là grünfeld très
agressif et caetera et caetera et or en
fait aux échecs aussi la psychologie qui
est importante
et quand tu joues un système très très
solide où tu te dis bah écoutes je joue
pour l'annuler un joueur plus fort que
toi
le vieil fortes souvent et si tu lui est
pas si mauvais que ça peut aller
chercher la victoire
il était quelqu'un sait combien ces
joueurs par rapport à droite ils étaient
à temps à l'époque moi je venais passer
2015 ils étaient 2000 sens je me
rappelle bien
c'était il ya 15 13 ans était un jeune
je suis plus qu'il fait maintenant ok
c'est un bon joueur quand même près d'un
bonjour non mais c'était et ça marche
beaucoup
tu vois c'est un peu comme dans l'east
indienne la variante avec fougue 3 sec
et tu échanges voix c'est un cas
particulier
je ne dis pas que c'est ça marche très
bien contre les 2003 2004 au dessus mais
quand tu joues à ce niveau là et que tu
comprends parce que les schémas sont
relativement faciles à comprendre et ben
ce je trouve que tu peux avoir un ratio
un ratio relativement intéressant non
madame
après personne mais ça ça marche jusqu'à
jusqu'à peut-être même 2003-2004 en
suivant les joueurs suivants les écoles
suivant un bien sûr on en plus si t'es
pas trop fait tu peux facilement je veux
le faible c'est 5 ça s'appelle un
mauvais premier strip au courant je peux
patiner toi et je vais vous donner le
dernier tournoi que j'ai fait l'année
dernière
eh bien écoutez j'ai battu deux 2150
et justement dans cette variante de
l'estadio naïf ou trois débats mais je
connais des 5 et je vais l'autre c'était
comme le gars qui me saoule chez mcqueen
fait pareil et j'ai changé je rentre en
finale et le gave forcément plus assez
finement avec notre ça n'a pas été très
précis mais c'était un cas voilà donc
pour ça que
par rapport au débat qu'on avait il ya
quelques semaines sur sur les grands
champions jusqu'en six minutes à moen
avec détroit ces trois à quatre blabla
je pense qu'il faut connaître ce qu'on
aime jouer aussi pour cheikh guèye qui
dit c'est comme trois poisons
pas de chance mais j'adore ça moi ou
trois ans de travaux et non j'adore ça
moi c'est très empoisonné quoi tu mets
le pion aux trois mois je vous ça tout
le temps mais en revanche contre quand
il s'appelle contrat meurs tu vois c'est
pas trop passait là par contre c'est
plutôt empoisonner tout d'un coup de
marteau le marteau lalalalala j'avais
mon poisson je ressens que le mec est
venu avec avec dix tonnes de dentifrice
je lui disais mais j'ai les dents
beaucoup trop propre dans cette partie
que l'on pouvait plus mais le mec même
femme on fera qu'on en parle ça pourrais
tu me prépares là dessus j'en ai marre
couasnon ne sert à rien foutu me prépare
contre amr en fait feu contre deux mecs
construit trois mecs en fait y sommes
préparés contre hammer et contre
méritais rien et bailleurs et tout le
monde est contre meilleur sur la
française parce que je joue pas trop
bien là rubinstein met donc du coup faut
que tu me prépares contre ces trois mecs
parce que j'ai très envie de les
défoncer bon france à l'occasion ce week
end
oui mais je le travail va être long et
compliqué je ne sais pas quand je ne
suis pas convaincu qu'on puisse y
arriver
bon sur ceux du coup qu'a réalisé trois
donc le mec tu dit très choqué mais
hélas alors deux choses qui me semblent
importantes
moi je vais vous proposer la re simple
un amateur qui a pas envie de se prendre
3 la tête et qui a envie de l'imiter
son répertoire d'ouvertures vous savez
on peut prendre des sacs et ça vous
permet d'avoir une autre la même balance
ne finisse candidat apparaît grand ouais
mais ça l'est pas terrible dit souhaiter
bon on s'écarte là normalement quand
même nom mais elle est pas top sales à
bondoufle ce cas là tu t'en fiches
non mais c'est pas avantageux long c'est
évident mais je veux ambulante mois
ouais mais non monsieur d'eau métro yaba
bellefroid guen mais manquait non mais
c'est pas spécialement bien sûr c'est
pas à eux 5 s'est mieux je pense
d'ailleurs que prendrait mais ouais tu
fais jamais trop dépenser
alors moi je voulais tuer comme ça
ouais mais bon et après tu fais pions
prend food est devant non mais c'est un
peu insipide ce truc la tension monte ma
tête j'y crois pas trop quoi nous sommes
à 85
plus incisif le v5 c'est beaucoup mieux
alors voilà donc 5 est donc là il ya en
gros il ya trois variantes importante
est celle que je voudrais vous présenter
qui c'est celle de ses une partie que
j'avais apprécié que j'avais découvert
en 1983 et avait été jouée je sais pas
si vous vous rappelez
on parle toujours du magazine europe
échec il y avait un ancien magazine que
j'aimais beaucoup qui s'appelait la
revue des échecs secte avec gambit sco
j'écoute du bureau lire deux fait des
trucs qui s'était de la fédération salon
maroc en viscose c'était un truc à part
mais ils ont dû fermer peut-être qu'il
allait passer de lecteurs je sais pas en
fait mes choix et ça maintenant
ouais c'était pas mal c'était je crois
que c'était deux sociétés dans le nord
de la france si quelqu'un dans le chatt
connaissent souvient que pour le lien
mais oui ça lui fermé dans les années 90
serait tandis que quand tu vois moi je
peux laisser la revue les échecs qui
avait disparu aussi par la suite et
c'est très intéressante que tu avais
notamment nicolas giffard qui était
devant et qui est donc champion de
france 78 82 et notamment il en donne un
des premiers dans un des premiers
numéros ils traitent ils traitaient de
l'open de paris 1983 ou taveri prier
avec son gang belgrade et tout ça et qui
t'expliquent et des variantes et et ceci
et cela est battu avec notamment cette
partie de hardin contre schuhl et
harding et un joueur qui a qui a
travaillé beaucoup par correspondance et
je tools est très intéressante que c'est
un luxembourgeois
et comme ce que si tu veuilles à passer
de beaucoup de grands maîtres au
luxembourg
il était souvent qualifier pour les
euros nos voix à l'émission donc en fait
il a une très belle carrière qu'il a
rencontré vraiment des joueurs
à fait impressionnante c'est quand les
français étaient avec les pays-bas la
belgique si je me rappelle bien il y
avait le luxembourg et tout ça et bien
je tout l'été toujours là quoi
mais il veut votre enfant tu sais ça
c'était assez intéressant et je me
rappelle je crois qu'il a fait le zonal
de 1990 ou 89 ou lautier d'ailleurs
éclater tout le monde et je prend une
raclée par lautier si vous l'avez il a
fait une belle carrière dues à son duo
ça nos services à ses intérêts donc
c'est toujours garder en chef chez moi
maintenant je crois plus qu'à toulouse
comme ça qu'on a un slim et vengeresse
où c'était pas mal je ne sais si ce
thème en fait tu fais quand même 100
boer a eu son grand battre alberto
calgary naheed thierry fait un match
contre vlad quoi oui ce jour toujours là
toujours là vlad avait gagné assez
facilement
je crois que oui et après je pense que
valent les faits un match contre adams
voyage au renom comme une âme en échange
elle fait match nul j'aurais eu de doute
ils avaient fait match nul je pense
one-77 gagnant +1 ils avaient fait nul
je sais plume à l'époque adams faisait
partie des tous meilleurs joueurs du
monde
exactement et à cette époque la faire je
puisse sèchement c'était nul 1 1 je
pense est elle aussi mal époque faire
annuler le contrat dames s'étaient
croisés parti quoi aucune ombre
oui mais c'était très chaud quoi faf
c'est comme si aujourd'hui tu jouais
contre gries tchouk quelque part excusez
moi et s'il fait match nul sur six
parties comptent great flu que c'est
chaud et je pense et les vrais matchs
contre piquet tenant aussi y avait un
match un peu piqué qui était battu mu
luis pabon lui je suis sur ce match
était-il a perdu contre adams d'un point
quand même adapt raison je pourrais
vérifier les sas a joué dans le club de
cannes à l'époque ce truc là exactement
je me rappelle être allé à cannes échecs
regarder le match va tu as et c'était
quand même une autre époque quoi les
échecs en france et un kahn était un
très grand club avant que tu prennes pas
me sens là bas on peut et qui les a été
coulé non non c'est quand je suis parti
en fait non mais ce que tout ça j'avais
ma licence à cannes quand ça s'est passé
c'est après que je me suis barré c'est
faut quand même remettre des trucs à
leur place
et là le truc ouais mais non majeurs que
les allées à l'époque les échecs en
france dans les années 90 jours
j'imagine que dans un club d'échecs en
france tu avais un match avec avec un
mec était membre du top 10 mondial le
faire c'est un truc qu'on pourrait plus
imaginer aujourd'hui 2 litres essence ça
demanderait des budgets colossaux de
faire ça aujourd'hui ce serait même plus
possible des colossaux comparé au
football n'en sais rien oui mais comparé
aux échecs c'est ce serait énorme
aujourd'hui de faire jouer un match a
great choquant
en six parties contre un autre mec ça
demanderait quand même des budgets assez
assez grand pour les clubs d'échecs
m'étonne c'est que lorsqu'il faut aux
etats-unis la série basse et 50000 $ par
joueur sept cent mille dollars le match
prête à céder budget qui sont plus
humains cas et bien c'est pour ça qu'il
faut absolument qu en france on est un
futur président de la république qui
regarde ce qui se passe en allemagne qui
regarde ce qui se passe au werder de
brême qui regarde ce qui se passe au
bayern munich les clubs de football et
ce sont eux qui financent des clubs de
l'est club d'échecs aller mais c'est
assez logique
et voilà à partir du moment où tu as pas
de modèle économique
eh bien il faut que devient mais sous
traitants une autre activité comme le
football bush en pour simplifier toutes
les autres activités
eh ben c'est une bonne façon de financer
de financer les échecs et tu sais que
cette manière de financer lesparre - - -
connu existe aussi en union soviétique
d'ailleurs c'était un peu le système
c'est que tu re devait reverser les
gains l'égard des sportifs devaient être
reversés au ministère des sports qui
redistribuait aux autres sports en fait
oui mais y'a pas que la secte dernier la
moitié de 9 à tous de la moitié des
sommes que tu gagnais de véro fils est
aussi symptomatique mais là c'est le
système soviétique
oui madjer qui refile aux autres sports
pour qu'il ya un genre d'égalité entre
lesparre en fait donc là ce que tu dis
c'est pas du tout la même chose qu un
système qui est vraiment différent mais
gers et le même esprit c'est à petit un
sport qui peut vraiment énormément
d'argent et du coup elle en profite un
peu pour pour aider un peu les autres
sports pour qui une forme de justice
entre les sports quoi entre guillemets
oui mais par exemple laurent laurent
frayssinet meskiti jouer au werder
m'expliquer le système de financement
c'est à dire que en fait tu reçois le
club d'échecs reçoit en fait un
pourcentage du nombre d'entrées au
weserstadion donc le nombre de
supporters qui vont supporter le werder
pendant l'année en bundesliga
eh ben ils reçoivent un pur je crois que
c'était un pur sang tu vois il ya trop
d'armes est énorme
c'est énorme c'était ça a l'air de rien
mais c'est un bon moi j'appelle femme tu
as la tête et les jambes mais y met non
mais une logique en plus une vraie
logique et neurologique tu imagines si
le psg venait ça
mais j'y pense c'est la folie on doit
jouer pour la hisser ce chèque à a pas
bien j'en ai parlé avec l'un des deux
président de la fcc samara pas et on dit
non toi tu vas payer pour mettre le mal
n'est ce pas si on va se refaire un peu
de fric sur toi théâtre off ça serait
très intéressant c'est à dire que fabien
va rembourser 1 % maintenant de ces gars
en tournant pour jouer dans notre club
le système inverse mais en fait pour la
laisser seule idée très simple c'est
qu'en fait ça permettait parce qu'en
fait comme tous les jeunes de
saint-etienne sont évidemment intéressé
par la fse je parle sous le contrôle de
ben en fait ceux qui n'ont pas la
capacité d'aller dans les centres de
formation d'aller à lectra par points
évidemment il ya une énorme sélection et
ben tu peux développer un club d'échecs
développera exactement avec le maillot
de marketing caetera et bien une idée de
saint-etienne est une idée de la fse et
j'en ai parlé avec le maire de
saint-etienne de cette idée il était
tout à fait d'accord
surtout quand je lui ai dit que lyon
était pressant aux échecs et qui avait
donc une concurrence évidente et moi
j'ai l'impression de problème c'est à
partir du moment où tu arrives à un
certain niveau
comment se voir expliquer des choses
comme ça à nos fameux responsables
soient que dans le monde du foot où dans
le monde et d'échec je sais pas pourquoi
ils comprennent pas donc je sais pas je
sais pas si c'est lié au centralisme à
la française si c'était un homme
jacobinisme 6 et j'obtiens quoi mais
c'est dingue c'est complètement dingue
non mais ça arrivera de toute façon ça
doit céder décision qui doit être qu'ils
doivent être prises à des niveaux
supérieurs en fait pas forcément un
patron de club français de football par
exemple peut très bien comprendre le
mode de financement des clubs d'échecs
et de l' avantage que ça alors que ça
leur rapporte
on a de la corse avec le nombre de
licenciés ya encore ce pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sont pas affiliés je pense à léo
battesti
mais c'est très spéculatif à ce que je
dis hein mais pourquoi toujours financer
ça par de l'argent public
pourquoi ne pas développer sa via des
clubs de football comme ajaccio comme
bastia et cetera ça permet aux gamins
d'avoir une identité culturelle très
forte de se rapprocher alors comme de
foot
les gamins jouent au foot à juba au jeu
d'échecs tout le temps et en même temps
pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas intégrer
des centres de formation de jouer aux
échecs et tu vois d'avoir des
communautés différentes mais qui ont des
buts communs oui oui oui non mais bon je
comprends le système un mois ça me
paraît assez intéressant mais le truc
c'est que ça va être très difficile à
mon avis de faire bouger les clubs de
foot dans cette direction en france en
tout cas de se tendre à 1 qu'il le
ferait ça donne envie aux autres
ouais mais bon après quand ils vont
aussi se rapprocher des machins des
divisions aux échecs des trucs qui vont
c'est tellement compliqué on est
tellement c'est tellement tout est
tellement compliqué que haut après tu
fais un championnat parallèle quoi tu
t'habilles un échec où il ya que les
clubs sont ligue 1 de foot elles vont du
coup tu vas pas être à la société à la
fédération d'échecs ont fusé c'est c'est
très compliqué en france on est dans un
pays qui est très bureaucratique un tas
aussi ça aussi ça qui peut freiner un le
fort le problème c'est qu'à force
d'avoir des personnes qui ne pensent pas
de futur de ce qui va se passer on sait
très bien les échecs ont explosé vers le
mode de système français à mon avis va
complètement exposées ouais c'est pour
bientôt à mohéli ben écoute moi pas je
peux pas j'ai des informations à ce
niveau là notamment sur les moyens de
financement des associations en france
quelle qu'elle soit
il ya c'est pas que les échecs ça va
exploser parce que il ya plus d'argent
mais c'est ça l'afrique et deux parce
qu'on va demander de plus en plus aux
associations un compte-rendu remet en
gros de ce que vont alors de leur donne
les derniers les régions ce que tu veux
mais bien aimé mais tu sais le lab on
part en part l'un suit qu'il ya un peu
qui est un peu éloigné mais quand on
lève la taxe d'habitation que tu fais
faire une économie à 8 milliards d'euros
d'un tutu demande un effort de 8
milliards d'euros mairies françaises
elles vont pas elle non pas faire des
économies en premier lieu sur la police
sur les routes ou quoi savoir faire les
économies sur les trucs qui sont entre
guillemets inutile oui en gros tout un
club d'échecs ou pas dans ta ville la
ville elle tourne quand même donc
forcément ça aura une répercussion là
dessus c'est obligatoire c'est logique
c'est comme si dans ta famille on
t'enlève de l'argent et tu vas tu vas
faire quoi tu vas tu vas tu vas moins
aller au cinéma tu vas - face et les
loisirs qui vont prendre assez sûr et
c'est comme ça c'est la logique ça se
prépare
le problème c'est qu'on ne prépare pas
donc c'est plus pareil non non mais non
bien sûr qu'on ne prépare pas bien sûr
qu'on le prépare comme mais on pressent
ici ont préparé les choses à l'avancé ça
serait quand même pourquoi préparé quand
on peut se retrouver dans la merde fins
il ya un mur si tu veux bon il est dans
500 m du coup ils font référence en
matière et c'est ça je remet un petit
coup d'annexer la fin je me rapprochais
milite surtout par rapport aux échecs ou
tout de même les l'économie digitale va
changer beaucoup de choses c'est dire
que moi j'ai aucune envie aujourd'hui de
masse créant un club d'échecs pour aller
taper trois heures de route les
week-ends sur internet pour jouer aux
échecs
bah oui mais c'est l'avenir des échecs
internet de tri façon le problème c'est
que l'ancien modèle te dis mais non
c'est comme ça qu'on doit faire
mais tu sais qu aux autres aux états
unis sas a déjà bougé dans les
interclubs les interclubs par pardon
peuvent déjà se jouer par internet géré
ça ils ont déjà évolué ils ont déjà
évolué là dessus il te suffit juste
d'avoir un arbitre dans la salle de jeu
de ton club et tu peux jouer par
internet
logique donc mais ça ça devrait exister
ça devrait exister depuis longtemps
c'est très logique
c'est très très logique parce que les
frais que ça engendre pour les clubs
d'aller voir même en n1 n2 d'aller taper
de 800 morts le week-end les hôtels et
machin c'est énorme en termes de frais
c'est je vais passer c'est pas des
déplacements qu'à nice c'est des
déplacements cannes toulouse fra ger
faut arrêter au bout d'un moment les
gens travaillent aussi fins
c'est n'importe quoi on te demande de
faire ça dans des divisions amateurs
parce que la nationale 1 fin c'est que
des joueurs amateurs quasiment et oui on
est d'accord
donc tu peux tu t'étais aucun sport qui
demande à des amateurs de faire de tels
déplacements
c'est comme ça oui oui mais on on prend
confiance car le truc en am non mais je
vais je vais le donner un exemple il ya
eu des élections à la fédération
française il ya deux ans maintenant
quelque chose comme ça un an ou deux ans
je vois un ami et j'avais été en contact
avec l'un des candidats est le gars mais
évidemment c'est à l'époque on ne savait
pas s'il y avait beaucoup d'argent à la
fédération française
il ya eu toutes ces rumeurs vous savez
on venait de perdre bp le fameux
sponsoring bnp paribas est le gars me
parle donc je n'ai pas donné son nom il
me parle il me parle d'un super centres
à paris dans les beaux quartiers
toi et moi je lui dis tu attends
s'affairent à quoi ça sert à quoi
aujourd'hui d'avoir un centre pour une
fédération notamment aux échecs à partir
du moment où où l'économie digitale est
là juste est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
tout simplement délocaliser les centres
les autres c'est des choses complètement
folles on n'a pas besoin aujourd'hui
pour entrer les différentes données on
n'a pas besoin d'avoir un centre en
plein centre de paris dans des beaux
quartiers qui coûte cher aux loyers et
une dîme et il faut faire beau il faut
faire beau par rapport à qui non mais
faut il dire faut faire beau faut
surtout faire vos danses que d'organiser
que des trucs que tu organises soit a
soit attrayant pour pour les sponsors
mais c'est très rarement le cas
et oui cette raison quand tu vois la
joie et le championnat de france je suis
passé pour regarder avait de chanter à
championnat de france rapide en ce
moment là il y avait plus de gens qui
regardent l aréna kings que j'ai joué la
semaine dernière c'est quand même
c'est quand même un peu étonnant pour un
sponsor quoi que tu es un connard qui
joue un tournoi de débiles sur internet
entre guillemets 1 et que ce soit plus
regarder qu'un championnat de france 28
essais f1 je sais pas y'a quand même un
souci quelque part oui mais enfin la
thématique est super intéressante c'est
à dire que plutôt que de faire ce qu'on
est entre guillemets en train de faire
là c'est à dire de dire c'est pas bien
c'est il faut se mettre autour d'une
table et réfléchir qui sait quoi
l'avenir
comment ça se passe comment ça se fait
quand même lorsqu'on parle on parle
beaucoup d'identité en france un mot que
j'aime pas trop comment ça se fait que
le bayern munich l'un des clubs les plus
prestigieux de football finance finance
en omnisports un club d'échecs
tu vois sans a priori pour comprendre ce
qui se passe moi j'en ai marre
d'entendre des clubs de football me dire
mais nous on évite d'en quitter la
région on ait une identité de ceux ci
non tout ce qui nous intéresse et les
abonnements c'est tout les mecs
développement rien à côté
non mais c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est sûr
après sa femme qui est compliqué pour
faire un truc constructif mais enfin
d'après enfin dans de mon point de vue
le digital c'est l'avenir des échecs
c'est évident il ya depuis qu'il ya
internet il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui
se sont remis aux échecs parce que c'est
un jeu qui est devenu beaucoup plus
accessible combien de fois moscou j'ai
vu des gens jouer dans le métro aux
échecs sur leur smartphone mais ça
arrive très souvent il est clair que ça
ça aide vraiment les échecs il faut
vraiment se tourner vers des acteurs du
digital pour développer notre jeu c'est
évident la ffe et devrait essayer de
faim pas que la ffe la fille d où quoi
de faire des partenariats avec avec des
[Musique]
acteurs de l'économie digitale avec
google bargach google quand ils ont
voulu faire leur l'heure
[Musique]
le web la leur machin de d'intelligence
artificielle ils ont pris quoi comme jeu
legault et les échecs c'est à dire que
les échecs c'est encore porter pour pour
le pour le domaine informatique et pour
les sociétés d'informatique
et du monde digital en général donc il
ya des choses à faire clairement votre
choix une bonne image
ça a toujours une bonne image c'est
juste que c'est très poussiéreux quoi il
faut dépoussiérer mai mais sinon c'est
une très bonne image vous regarde le
quotidien ils ont ils ont ils soir les
refaire un reportage championnats de
france jeunes il avait parlé de notre
chaîne dans l'eure dans leur émission
dont les échecs ça fait quand même
parler encore tu es ab saab seule voix
sur sa chaîne il fait des parties
d'échecs
il ya quand même pas mal de gens qui
sont venus aux échecs après ces vidéos
et les parties qu'on a joué avec ap salt
a déjà fait plus de 50000 vu sur
internet par vidéo enfin tu vois c'est
énorme quand ils pensent cinquante mille
bus qui regarde un truc d'échec donc
et tu sais que dans les gens connus en
france qui se sont mis aux échecs ta
squeeze je sais pas si tu connais pour
moi ce n'est pas bien parce quizy c'est
un des seuls mecs sur youtube en france
qui a 10 millions d'abonnés
c'est pas le gars qui regardent des
conneries à longueur de temps et il ya
des millions de personnes qui n'en est
pas là et puis lui il est assez marrant
ils jouent à des jeux et machins et non
c'est pas mal tu peux regarder sur
youtube c'est assez marrant mais géré
par la tat des mecs comme ça qu'ils qui
pourrait largement développé une
audience pour les échecs qui serait
possible de tu vois c'est vers des gens
comme ça qu'il faut se tourner vers des
sociétés de l'internet qui sont des
acteurs de l'internet aujourd'hui et qui
peuvent être intéressés par les échecs
pour plein de raisons
oui mais bon revenons à nos moutons
voilà il ya un mouton e51 donc la route
à trois variants moi je voulais vous
parler de d4 web
pour simplifier les noirs peuvent jouer
cavalier des faits que je pouvais ce qui
a valu un cas tout pousser des caps
d'accor sa sur cavaillé 17 ya une
variante que je trouve très intéressante
c'est de jouer aussi ce jouet reprend
des 4 par exemple 3 4 donc c'est un
véritable sacrifice de pions c'est un
appel à une attaque de nuit je crois que
je sais pas là je connais pas le sud un
en russie c'est que tu es tu mets les
pieds comme saab ont bloqué le fou et
jouer sur la case de 5
parce que pratiquement c'est très
compliqué à jouer on l'a c'est pas
évident à jouer
c'est un peu chiant à écrire sur qui a
valu au kata voilà il ya un petit coup à
connaître ces il faut justement tu
virton cavaliers et les deux cessez le
feu
voilà et ensuite peinture chassera du
chat sera le cavalier henri iv et la
malle dans de faire d'un v6 comme dans
les carreaux cannes
donc c'est aussi très intéressant de
jouer ces variantes et en général alors
j'ai pas pousser l'analyse qu'en général
les blancs sont bien donc c'est c'est
assez intéressant mais là la baronne que
je voulais vous montrer ses des caps et
là encore une fois on va rentrer dans
une forme de finale en échange en tout
donc le pré m6
tu prends assez froid tu prends auger
s'est passé à peu près forcé un peu ce
que tu feras angers 7 6 reprend g7 on va
prendre ses trois en or un pion de plus
il peut pas prendre b2 parce qu'on prend
à chaud suite on fait damer on protège
ans
un don qu'il doit prendre en d2 dame
prend des deux ponts des deux places et
quasi forcée parce que sinon les blancs
échanger des robes donc ce qui est plus
logique de prendre ici et vous prendrez
cette voie là et bien évidemment alors
est ce que tu te revenir au 6e coup
ouais donc que d'un pro d2 parce que
j'ai vu que le grand maître hector le
grand maître suédois hector qui et qui
apporte de nouvelles idées
bonne ou mauvaise échec et bien lui il a
développé ces dernières années une autre
variante qui est très intéressante si
les gens veulent un un jeu un peu plus
dynamique et ben c'est de faire fou
prend des deux à la place de d'un point
des deux coups de vent la foudre en d2
donc évidemment que je vous prends g7 et
la dame est roi juste une petite idée
donc je tu sais vous prend b2 c'est fou
ces 4 et dans le cas alors vous donne
juste une variante extrême
si tu fais le son prend à un fou prendre
un oui qu'est ce que je veux dire
batta fou premier set où elle fut alors
je montrais justin 17 à l'acte hattmatt
évidemment airways fita fois çi ce plu
j'ai fais tu là si je me trompe pas tu
dois avoir foi aussi ça tu connais le
dalmate
c'est tout simple alors évidemment faut
pas prendre à 1 mais ça montre un petit
peu comment cette position qui a l'air
de rien de très très haut niveau
enfin voilà c'est ça et en partie rapide
je pense que ça peut être extrêmement
dangereux même en partie aux normales ou
alors pire tu feras tour des 1 et s'est
fait autour d un etat du jeu en tout cas
et tu vois c'est pas évident à jouer tu
étais tu n'y es là c'est intéressant
d'être carrément mieux non ouais bof
oui ça c'est énorme et oui il faut de
précis et c'est clair qu'en bon jeu
rapide en plus et anaïs côté blank du
pot 2 par surprise tu sais tout par
coeur tu as bien compris tes idées
souhaitent les pièces passé
ces désagréments c'est une autre manière
plutôt dame président
au final donc en d2 pareil tu penses
quoi
et là évidemment tombe sous hégémonie at
on donc la b2 est menacé par exemple pas
sacrifier un sens les dames c'est pas
possible donc grand roque évidemment
défend de trouver 2 et là on va
continuer à se développer normalement
les noirs vont jouer comme à la partie
qui avait ses six donc tu cloud foulée
5-fu décès hélas alors que la théorie
donne plutôt qu'aller à 3 bat toi qui
joues qu alger au 12 mai a fondu faut
quand même souligner que tu as un petit
avantage avec les blancs dû à la
structure de pions 1 parce qu'il ya
trois îlots contre deux et c'est
exactement ça en fait cette variante
c'est que moi je veux tout simplement
jouer deux îles option contre 3 et si on
dit valet noir ont bien joué ils ont
fait nul très bien et s'ils sont un peu
moins bien achevée je vais les travaillé
pendant toute la partie pour simplifier
et donc tu penses que tu ne peux pas
perdre quoi fou si tu fais pas d'erreur
grossière il c'est difficile de perdre
cette partie avec les blondes en tout
cas cieux pas la force et qui fait rien
de spécial c'est sûr que tu vas pas la
perdre et c'est le seul cas où tu la
perds donc alors tant qu est ce qu on a
joué cavalier 2 bat évidemment au grand
roque pareil là tu joues ces trois ont
été changés changer de voie là c'est
l'idée de cavalia 2 qui revient et donc
la bombe à la différentes possibilités
mais dans la partie je te le foot pro c3
qui est tout à fait logique et là en
fait les jetons il va jouer un coup
c'est tout à fait logique mais qui en
fait sa paire direct presque et c'est
compliqué c'est qu'il a joué tour tour
g8 on va courage et 8 pardon alors là
qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire un
truc comme camaïeu 5 pour liquider non
je pense pas tant qu'il y avait le
simple qu'est ce que tu fais là dessus
tu prends pas nos têtes retour un
derrière avec f4 crise est passée par là
c'est pas évident mais tu peux rien
c'est un peu chiant et non alors j'avais
regardé un petit peu apparemment de
meilleurs coûts à la place de tours g8
pâturages et 8 c à 6 mai la télé blanc
sont bien ils vont venir tranquillement
rousset 4 par exemple ils vont amener
leur tour en 1
non mais c'est un peu chiant à jouer ça
c'est sûr voilà c'est ça en fait l'idée
si tu veux pourquoi j'aime beaucoup
cette partie et que ça a l'air de rien
mais bon et puis voilà si la partie
entre guillemets c'est qu'ils vibrent tu
vas te manger trois mois jugés pro f 4
par exemple et on va essayer de créer un
pion passé si possible du côté de la
droite
voyez c'est un peu l'idée donc à la pâte
d'arachide à 6 da jouer un coup que je
trouve très naturel pour que g8 pour un
g8 pardon et là tu vas commencer bon ben
voilà l'idée semble bonne heure
j'aimerais sa prise prises et wayne du
couffin pour montrer un même problème
c'est sain est en fait surtout pas
exactement
nantes a été malin déjà tour chez lui
après tout huit thèmes à l'ol mais fait
un coup naturel et à temps et si fait
genre tour des huit as et du coût de la
partie radja m avantage peut pas faire
russie s'abstint c'est chiant et la
fourchette en abscisse assez horrible et
puis si tu ramènes le tour en fait pour
jet tours pour ge i et bata un peu la
même idée donc déjà que demande la
question pourquoi j'ai perdu un temps
quoi et battu pareil tu fais tout à
cheveux sains et sûrs au voc le 6 on
sait aussi ta khalef si quelque chose
comme ça mais voilà et tu joues avec lui
au final tu étais super bien ouais ouais
on est gagnante c'est là je sais pas à
quel point les gagnantes mais en tout
cas est largement des autres télés
largement bien vrai
c'est un peu l'idée donc après calais b
les blancs jouer c'est ton idée retour
des 8es l'appareil qui revient tour à
chaud un buffet réussit sa cause de la
fourchette et là tu es déjà très mal
déjà très mal donc les blancs les noirs
par don shula préféré prolonger le bail
au bord du précipice
il va prendre cette petite combine les
petites combines qui allaient procès
tout reprend pourquoi os car lé point
qu'elle est pas fou prend ou prend
évidemment tu peux pas les en dés 8
parce qu'il ya fois je te vois
évidemment différent dès les 8es
l'appareil aux cheveux en philadephie
cavaliers s'est amorcée voilà tours 8
et gagne le créneau est en fait d'une
position qui a l'air relativement égale
qui paye pas de mine comme ça claudio
bat échanges ridan ceci et cela
en fait je la trouve très intéressant
mais là c'est un peu mieux pour les
blancs c'est sûr ça c'est sûr que c'est
pour les blancs tatatata une meilleure
structure de pion est un meilleur
développement c c et 5 c sur que les
blancs sont un peu mieux là et c'est la
baronne principal en plus tu vois de
cette ligne donc ça montre que le bass
on va dire la balle est dans le camp des
noirs donc ça veut dire que tu dois
jouer absolument soit qu'à valider fait
une fois cabello cac gagne pas évident
non mais t'es un décès ces normes qui
est pas facile ça me rappelle une partie
de maxime contre gratchev si les gens
veulent retrouver sur la chaîne youtube
ils pourront retrouver s'il va le
chercher et non mais c'est pas tout à
fait ça la position évidemment mais
c'est une sicilienne qui a fini un peu
avec cette structure de pion dans
l'esprit donc s'ils veulent un peu
approfondir ils pourront mais c'est
jamais facile à jouer comme structure de
pions pour les noirs parce que tu sais
toujours difficile est de développer le
souci avec ça fait un mur au milieu de
l'échiquier qui ceint d'un chiant de
côté
tel est le rôle elle dame est en fait
les le roi des noirs est difficile à
défendre avec les blancs on pourra
toujours se fout des trois soit la dame
peut arriver sinon avec g63 toujours h 4
h 5
et c'est très rapide et en plus tu es
une belle 4e simple rien mais c'est ça
que je trouve sympa à jouer comme je
vous l'aï dit j'ai vu sur internet à des
très près jouer hors parti de cinq
minutes on bildt alors peut-être aussi
les mecs ils jouent sans grande
conviction à ce qu'ils font gagner ses
trois ans blitz ça dépend quel niveau tu
as regardé
bon je dois je te dis sa tribu ouais
alors après ce qu'ils ont joué avec les
mêmes idées
que toi qui sont quand même assez assez
sophistiqué où est ce qu'ils on veut
juste pour éviter de rentrer dans la
théorie tu vois tout ce que je peux te
dire aussi c'est que des trois c'est
assez mauvais ah bon bah après ces 5
ouais tu te rends se pose pas dans une
super bonne fight rando du signal n'est
ce pas forcément la vente de rêve et f4
s'est séparé au nom mais si tu peux
jouer sa meilleure part la sepa sepa fou
quoi faut mieux faire ton truc avec
cavaliers c3 sait pas quand il est
intéressant je trouve ça un peu ce
détroit il ya même des cinq mois
pourquoi option n'est pas allée qui il a
joué ces cinq comptes mais pas bon gros
sur cahier des deux parents keira autres
5 c'est une fille dans sa version
bon enfin c'est jouable pour les blancs
mais bon pour coup c'est pas par c'est
sûr ça peut être vraiment âge et mes
trucs et c3 j'aime mieux que d'être
aussi en fait un nom mais il ya une
belle partie d'une belle victoire de
dalé qui n'y participent et reconnu en
plus contre tomasz dans ce foot là vous
avez contre les pions pendant mais il a
été très vite bien et c'est juste enfin
il ya aucune idée enfin là ton truc avec
alice et 3 est quand même des idées
comment dire pour essayer de prendre
l'aventage quoi avec les blancs qui
aurait pour avantage là tu vois même
plus pour l' avantage c'est comme une
sicilienne avec détroit quand même face
à un peu triste aussi
wahou fois je suis pas fan âge d'or
c'est bien de jouer avec des si ce n'est
celle des trois jeunes et des joueurs
moi j'aime lingots ouais ouais m'enfin
non mais je préfère ton truc qui a été
hissé 3 enfin le système remporte chez
saint pol ou ouais je sais pas si à
toucher un niveau dont tu parles 1700
1800 suis pas si les gens vont bien
gérer ce truc là quand même avec les
blancs je crois beaucoup plus sans ton
truc avec cavalli c3 qu'on se construit
avec des trois noms mais je suis en fait
parce qu'elle est toute simple
là ça a l'air de rien tu as l'impression
qui a rien du tout dans tactiquement il
suffit d'une petite précision pour que
les blancs prennent très très clairement
leur avantage et ça nécessite pas une
autorisation terrible pour les blancs
l'idée est tout ça donc voilà non mais
c'est pas mal c'est pas maintenant
franchement je situe à éviter la les
kings tu m'as convaincu avec ton truc
avec un essai 3 je préfère largement
le truc avec détroit depuis sa force sa
force les noirs si tu veux c'est quand
même des synthés le coup naturel pour
les journalistes parce qu'ils vont pas
vouloir jouer au sein qui vont pas
pouvoir jouer aux dés 6 sinon ça leur
force à faire différentes variantes en
plus à prendre différentes variantes en
plus je trouvais ça intéressant
voilà état et à penser à d'autres que
vous protégez le pion du cou où il n'y a
rien d'autre
non non non pas spécialement
et a déjà vu cette petite variante là
qui peut être marrante des cas c'est
quoi ça va peut être vous des six
statues quoi ouais ils veulent reprendre
le 5 avec lecavalier en fait d'accord
c'est quoi c'est une petite variante qui
a été jouée par karpatchev nous parce
qu' il ya un ami de vlad en fait il ya
qu'à laisser trop sur des quatre ans que
je me dis que non mais wafa soit là
soi-même c4 c5 qu'ils y aillent comme ça
tu veux dire mais là aussi ça doit être
jouable en multijoueur
ouais ça devrait être jouable avec
l'idée de reprendre 2d et ont été
brassés d'evian doublé après vrai ça
doit exister aussi est plein de ligne
mais socle davantage de questions trop
deuxième coup s'est battu jusqu'au bout
de développement naturel tu défends ton
pions et à dépit des idées
le daily mail montre et des autres qui
est un peu dans l'est dans l'esprit de
polo qui sont moins connus entre
guillemets ouais mais une fois on en
vient à toi notre discussion ya quelques
semaines c'est je suis pas 400 donc à
partir de ce moment là j'essaie de jouer
des bars ans que je comprends et où je
me sens à l'aise
donc voilà c'est l'ordinateur va me dire
que eu 5 au deuxième coup c'est
évidemment meilleur coup mais c'est pas
grave parce que psychologiquement les
jordan et ils vont il ya très peu de
choses qui se remettent à jouer simple
pas un truc marrant et sylvain était au
complet mais il y avait ça mais j'ai pu
commencer à ce jour ne marche pas trop
en fait
ouais mais je crois que tu veux prendre
f set mais c'est ça oui mais c'était un
très bon moment comme truc mais ça
devrait être assez mauvais je pense
bah ouais en fait
la dame c'est ridicule en fait j'adore
ah oui en fait le truc enfin tu pourrais
penser que ça ça marche mais ça va pas
marcher c'est ça le délire j'étais déçu
mais je pensais juste le faire comme ça
en fait
mais bon c'est pareil ça marche aussi
assez horrible c'est vrai que la
seine-et-marne comme étant du raid en
fait a pas beaucoup de coups quoi enfin
sorti de là était un peu bloquée sortie
des trois quilles 5 ha oui vous détroit
ce début d'année c'est 300 de visas
n'ont été ces trois ou cinq c'est que
l'art dans les meilleurs c'est 300 c'est
sûr que c'est mieux
voilà bah hockey basketball marceau
ouais merci merci c'est intéressant je
vais peut-être le jouet du coup ton truc
je dirai ce que ça donne d'accord des
prochaines arena king benoît et toi t'es
pas pour jouer les contres les autres
rames ok mais mon problème en fait c'est
sa fab a il est 21h30 mais bon on juste
pour te dire que mon problème c'est le 3
poison contre meilleures passes et à des
blancs ouais j'ai les blancs je sais
plus comment il fait savoir garder mais
en fait il me fait un truc où il va vite
vite vite me jouer à eux cinq s'est pas
fait jouer 3 avec des cas moi je suis
pas d'éclatement et lui faudra qu'on
regarde et le problème contre mérite
hirian alors là il est beaucoup plus
grave c'est qu'il me joue cette variante
là je n'arrive pas quoi j'arrive
vraiment pas mais je n'arrive pas du
coup je sais pas quoi lui joue en fait
le tableau présente les blancs bon je
fais 4e trois noms dominent aussi il me
domine aussi il me domine partout en
fait mais je peux faire ça peut-être oui
et du coup s'il fait ça je fais ça a
peut-être joué ça la prochaine fois et
je retarde le développement de lui moi
l'idée c'est que ces 5 tu fais ce 3 way
we say on va montrer ça avec celle joie
justement que dans celle là
ces quatre tas d'hommes se loger sa
nombreuse devient madame b 6 oui mais
c'était juste pour moi avec leurs noms
soient dans les systèmes b3 c4
quatre dom ces deux il faut être ça qui
marche pas il encaisse mais sur ça
alors que si tu as la même avec le
cavalier en f3 c'est ça que je pense à 6
baies la salle marche parce que castrés
était défendue cela va prendre tout faux
on prend ça va me prendre dans son
format la tour 1 et au jeu des siens et
c'est pas c'est pas prête à lui si le
truc qui m'a montré great shoot c'est
l'aïd coup de fer dame ces deux là il
m'a dit contre les mecs faible donc à
moins de 2005 soit 7,5 il veut faire de
5 sur les dcf with you kg battu plein de
mecs comme ça mais il serait facile quoi
il était très fier de ce truc là et
maintenant les mecs connaissent mais lui
faisais ça il ya peut-être cinq ans tu
vois mais mais là dessus du coup sûr
dames c'est de chez plus qu'il faut
faire mais c'est pas très grave
votre fierté g6 aussi je sais pas quoi
mais bon mais du coup c'est d'eux que
dame b 3 en réalité mais ouais parce
qu'en fait il me joue ça aussi contre le
système de londres non mais j'ai des
problèmes contre non mais contre le
système de londres comment il s'appelle
il me joue ça en fait ouais mais c'est
ça qui me fait il fait ça ça ça je fais
ça hein
il me fait ça tous les trois dans man
ray du coup là j'ai pris plusieurs fois
c'était mon nom mais quand je fais des
trois arrêts mais il a fait ça aussi
q beaucoup des droits ces deux vieux
coup sinon t'as fumé sont à oui c'est
vrai mais ça que j'oublie gelé dans ma
base en plus et c'est petit avantage de
lens a raté ce trail en fait j'ai trouvé
ça peut être échangé la meilleure
structure et une lutte contre une
personne simple non plus c'est en plus
j'ai ça dans mon ordinateur mais je suis
débile mais le truc c'est que j'ai
toujours pris de vitesse dans cet aréna
j'ai pas assez de temps pour mobiliser
je sais pas ça me serait ce déjà de
jouer hammer à chaque fois et
et tu te souviens de jouer contre 3,4
mais k 2000 2002 quoi et tout d'un coup
tu passes avec 1 meur et ça va très vite
ça s'enchaîne et je me trompe à chaque
fois mais oui pour pour dire foot est
roi tu peux faire aussi ici ou là et
messages et déjà analysé segal et que si
ce pas ce qu'ils font mais si ce nom
barrett a vu ses ventes avec toro 8,5 je
crois non pas pour moi mais tu vas
mettre le cavaliere au sein du coin je
sais plus qui font bloquer le 5 mai bien
mai foulée ça que ça va tu joues tu
luttes pour la vente âge ont pu gagner
ce prochain à rabat maroc et donc contre
hammers et bon après j'ai pris mon
contrat meurt avec les noirs mais ça
c'est un autre souci non mais le
problème c'est qu'avec les noirs qui
peut pas m'aider
le mec leurs ébats le mec connais bien
la scandinave et du coup je suis tout le
temps mal donc amarré quai nord tu peux
m'aider y joue le bon truc en fait ils
jouent ce truc avec food et 2g coach
pourquoi donc
non mais déjà je n'arrive pas trop mais
j'ai fait des trucs avec fougue et 4
mais il connaît assez bien et c'était un
massacre à chaque fois du coup mon plan
avec les noirs c'est de perdre vite pour
enchaîner les parties ne sais pas si
paulo tu connais bien le principe de cet
aréna king c'est dur quand même temps
une heure et demie deux réserves deux
arrêts en fait c'est pas attendant avec
un nombre de rondes c'est que tu joues
ton parti enfin tant celle des partis
pendant deux heures on va gagner vite
perdre vite c'est pas mal c'est que je
veux plus de parties donc marquer plus
de points
ouais ouais ouais t'as un truc sur
internet mais j'ai gagné a perdu tes
automatiquement rey a parié etc
ben je pourrais vous montrer un truc que
j'ai gagné plusieurs fois il faudrait
que mais je vais vous montrer un truc
fantastique que j'aie gagné hier et
après on vous laisse coi comme ça pour
l'os pas heureux j'ai une partie châssis
qui est bon c'est la dernière ronde du
truc quoi j'étais obligé de gagner vite
pour tenter de rattraper hammer
justement donc ok je vous savez c'est de
toujours et tempo bon et là le mec fait
d'amd 5 et au kef où je craque un petit
peu quoi je veux pas échanger les dames
ce que je vais gagner vite je fais mf4
fou petites fautes
bon c'était pâques ou de coiffes non
mais après ça va être apte à gagner ça
j'ai gagné avec la grande classe j'étais
très heureux le mec est venu et a taxé
le cavalier en d3 caligari quoi c'est ce
que tu vas expliquer femmes coiffe un
fou je défends tout quoi est vivant
après je reviens quoi et fif
j'ai revécu voiture afin fou je rate
avec des trucs et après j'ai fait un
petit chipeau je suis pas compris
pourquoi le mec qu'a pas échanger des
pièces
oui mon général conté nomme d'opus bonne
idée de changer tout est là j'ai fait un
truc fantastique
voilà j'ai attaqué aussi plus ou moins
et j'ai essayé depuis tout à l'heure de
planter carrieu 5 et vous tombez dans le
panneau
mais on remet cela s'est toujours pas
gagnant mais moralement atteindre ouais
mais en fait ce qui est marrant de ses
arénas paulo c'est que comme les parties
s'enchaînent pendant deux heures ça
c'était la dernière partie du tournoi et
quant à enchaîner deux heures de jeu
sans pause
c'est juste que tu as le cerveau qui est
qui en bouillie et donc les partis à la
fin peuvent être assez marrante c'est
drôle pas assez fun quelqu'un que je
vois assez bien nous dire comme ça ouais
mais après j'ai figé
sap a suivi c'était marrant comme fin de
comme dernière partie c'était cool
c'était cool pour valve sur ce les mecs
là merci merci à toi sur une pente
c'est sympa et qu'est ce que je voulais
zaba web on fera ce sera l'occasion quoi
bah moi je l'attesterait déjà donc si si
si je perds je tends voudrait parce que
c'est tu m'as convaincu quoi je vais
l'attesté d'accord bah écoute et au
plaisir
toto elle a bientôt merci beaucoup bonne
soirée